so now here with more on his plan to
make America great again the 45th
president of the United States Donald
Trump Mr President great to have you
back sir how are
you well thank you very much that is
some list you read off and you can
probably double in triple it it's so bad
I don't think we've ever been in a
position like this it's terrible what's
happened to our country in three
years well let's start in Iowa though um
the largest margin of Victory prior to
your 30 Point win on Monday was Bob Dole
in 1988 with about just under 133%
Victory margin um this is historic in so
many
ways how do you Analyze This what
happened why was this bigger than any
other uh Iowa
caucus because the Biden Administration
is so bad and we now have a contrast you
didn't have a contrast so much before
and now you have a contrast why what
happened you know we get the most votes
of any sitting president in history and
then somebody else takes over and they
take a look at what uh we had versus
what they have now and the difference is
so Stark it's so massive it's so
different the country is a different
place we were respected all over the
world we got the largest tax cuts ever
the largest regulation cuts ever we
rebuilt our military shown we did
everything even right to try you know
what right to try is if you know you're
able to use some of these incredible new
uh drugs that they're making bio drugs
and other drugs and people's lives are
being saved You' never could do it you'd
have to go to Asia you'd have to go to
Europe different places all over the
world now you get them here and that was
a hard thing they 58 years they tried to
get that if you were terminally ill they
didn't want to give you a drug even if
they thought it might work because they
said we don't want to hurt the people I
said no no they're terminally ill we're
going to do something and we got it done
it was not easy either because the drug
companies nobody wanted it the country
didn't want it they were worried about
liability people now sign a document
there's no liability and they can take
these drugs and Sean we're saving
thousands and thousands of lives it's
been an amazing Miracle we did so much
and you would have never had Ukraine you
would have never had the attack on
Israel none of these things and you
wouldn't have had inflation because I
had oil so low and now we have the exact
opposite we have a mess we have the
worst president in history well let me
ask you this and I love the state of New
Hampshire I love the people of New
Hampshire I don't like their primary
system for one reason they have what's
called an Open Primary uh already we
know that nearly 4,000 Democratic voters
have switched affiliation to Republican
or Undeclared meaning independent ahead
of the primary according to the
Secretary of State's office and it is
believed for example one woman who's uh
on a co-chair of of Nikki Haley's
campaign her own daughter a Democrat
changed her affiliation from Democrat to
Republican to vote for Haley in the
primary but even Governor sonunu not a
friend of yours told our own Neil Cavuto
that it's troubling that many of these
people that will switch as Democrats and
turn to Independence and vote in the
Republican primary that when push comes
to shove that they would choose Biden in
the end over any Republican I'm not that
fond of that system does that concern
you you you the real clear politics
average has you up by 13 the suff pole
just today I think had you up by 16 um
it was the CNN poll that had you up by
seven does that system bother
you it bothers me and the governor
should have done something about it
instead of talking waste his time with
Nikki because she's not going to make it
she has no chance she's got no way
maggot's not going to be with her and
you know when you said the Democrats
voting no it doesn't say that it said
about Nikki that 50% of the Republicans
would be lost to Nikki only to Nikki not
even to Ronda sanctimonia so you you
know it's a bad thing for her but it's a
bad thing for us who has a system where
Democrats are allowed to vote in the
Republican primary and New Hampshire's
an incredible place I love the people we
we won New Hampshire last time it was
fantastic what we did and you know we
have great spirit great everything but
you need a system you need a governor
that's going to get it changed not just
talking about it he's been talking about
it for four years never got it done so
Democrats are allowed to vote which
they're going to vote for her because
they don't want to run against me they
want to run against her you know it's a
very simple system uh we are leading
Biden in every poll Michigan just came
out we're leading by 11 uh Georgia just
came out we're leading by 13 points
we're leading everywhere now and she's
not you know she has one obsolete pole
that she likes she's about two months
old where she was leading Biden well
that those days are gone she's not
leading Biden anymore the problem is the
Democrats want her to run desperately so
they have a lot of Democrats signing up
in New Hampshire hire but I don't think
it's going to matter I saw one where
we're at 50 or 51 and she was at 34 I
believe and I think we're going to be in
very good shape like we were in if you
look at Iowa nobody knew we were going
to blow it out like that you know we
were at I think it finishes off close to
53 we' won by 30 somewhat points and
nobody thought that was possible we
doubled the all-time record more than
doubled I guess the alltime record I
think a similar thing's going to happen
here but here Independents and Democrats
are allowed to vote
so in order to try and stop Trump they
go out and they sign up and they can
sign up very easily and sonunu should
have stopped
it yeah let me ask you I mean you got a
lot of praise for your speech your
victory speech in Iowa and and people
noticed that you were particularly
gracious I noticed in the town hall the
last Town Hall we did together the one
you did with Brett and Martha um that
you seem to have taken on a a more
gracious Tone If if that's the way to
say it maybe the question I get asked
most often I've asked you this question
before you know why is Donald Trump
always fight so hard um Dennis Miller
brought this up on the program last
night a little bit of humility with
Donald Trump will go a long way yes he's
been persecuted his family has suffered
he suffered yes it's been unfair but he
fights hard he loves his country and and
sometimes maybe you shouldn't be as
personal what was your reaction to
that well I know it and I know it very
well but we also have to win Sean and if
I were uh a different type of person I
think I would have been out of office a
long time ago you wouldn't have even
gone through it they hit me with Russia
Russia Russia before the election even I
mean if you look at it it was before the
2016 election it was all set up and I
fired Comey I did a big job we got rid
of a lot of the deep State and I will
tell you uh you know then we had the
covid come two and a half years later
but nobody ever had a better economy we
had the greatest economy in the history
of our country we had the the strongest
Border in the history of our country I
built over 500 miles of wall we got
Mexico to give us 28,000 free soldes
free of charge that not that easy to get
by the way I had to do a lot of
maneuvering including tariffs and other
things to get it but we uh you know by
the way speaking of terrce we took in
hundreds of billions of dollars for from
China and of that we gave 28 billion to
our Farmers because they were abused by
China what China did to our Farmers was
horrible and we did a great job for our
country you know again the largest tax
cuts in history the Democrats want to
double up and triple up on the on the
taxes they want to double your taxes and
triple your taxes I got you the biggest
bigger than the Reagan tax cuts you and
I were talking about that the other day
and you called up about uh the Reagan
cuts and our Cuts our Cuts were
substantially bigger we got rid of the
death tax or the estate tax for farmers
and small manufacturers you know I mean
what we did was an amazing thing those
tax cuts and getting back and getting
back to your one part of the question
though we did all of that and we had to
fight off all of the witch hunts and the
scandals and the the horrible self the
these people what they did Russia Russia
Russia Ukraine Ukraine Ukraine 51
intelligence agents saying that the
laptop from hell was created by Russia
not by Hunter Biden okay it was Hunter
Biden all the way lie they lied to
Congress they lied to everybody two
impeachments that went nowhere they went
absolutely nowhere but I mean if I were
a softer individual and I'll tell you
something Ronda santz or Nikki or
anybody else if they were in my position
if they were here they would have been
hit just as hard these people play tough
much tougher than the Republicans play
and the Republicans have to get tougher
but Nikki would I know Nikki very well
she worked for me for a long time she
would not be able to handle that
position she would not be able to handle
the onslaught with all of that being
said within the Republican party I want
to bring Unity and within the nation I
want to bring unity and you know Unity
is going to come from success because
when we had this country prior to co and
then even after Co but especially prior
to co the China virus coming in we had
the most successful country ever in
history there's never been anything like
it what we did and you know the other
side was calling me and they were coming
to me they wanted to talk it was all
coming together success will bring
everybody under the same tent
you know I I I covered all of that I
cannot disagree with you and frankly
this show me personally I've been
Vindicated because as many networks
pedal their lies and conspiracy theories
uh we day in and day out we were peeling
every layer of the onion we we got the
the Russia hoax right uh as Vindicated
by the Hartz report the dorm report um I
I do want to ask you this the last time
I interviewed you I asked you if you
think that Joe Biden is going to be the
Democratic nominee and you said no do
you still feel that way and if you don't
think it's him who do you think is
likely to replace
them look he can't put two sentences
together he can't find the stairs off a
stage which there are a lot of them up
there believe me they're all over the
place he can't find his way off a stage
when he makes a very short speech and it
has to be short because it can't be long
he can't negotiate you look at what's
happening the whole world is blowing you
know Victor Orban the prime minister of
Hungary very tough guy smart guy
brilliant guy uh very respected but
tough they asked him what's going on
with the world he said one thing very
simple bring back Trump when Trump was
here everybody was afraid of trump now I
don't want to say that because I don't
like that word but he said it he's
probably the toughest leader over there
one of the toughest anywhere but highly
respect it and knows he gets it he said
you bring back Trump it's all going to
disappear they all respect Trump and
they were afraid of trump but they all
respected Trump and it's true Putin
would have never attacked Ukraine I got
along with Putin you know it's good to
get along with people like Putin and
like others uh you you take a look at
what's going on with China they're just
licking their chops right now to go into
Taiwan that would never even have they
wouldn't have even thought about it with
me and I had talks with President she I
have a great relationship if Hillary
Clinton would have won you would have
had a nuclear war with North Korea Kim
Jong-un I got along with him to nobody
ever got to talk to them except me and I
got not only talk to them I got along
with them great it's good to get along
with people that have massive nuclear
weapons and they have massive they have
a large nuclear stockpile so well I did
a job I did the job and we made America
great again and these people what
they're doing to our country they're
allowing millions and millions of people
to pour through just it's an invasion
into our country and they're coming from
prisons and they're coming from mental
institutions mental institutions and
insane asylums and prisons are being
emptied all over the world not just in
South America all over the world they're
being emptied out into our country we're
like a dumping ground and you know what
else is coming in terrorists are coming
in and we have to stop it this 11 months
or 10 months is a very dangerous period
we have been able to count the numbers
of people coming from Iran and Syria
thousands from Egypt thousands from from
Afghanistan 12,000 from Russia 26,000
from China showing up at our Southern
border um nobody's ever going to
convince me that they are that all of
them are coming here for a better life
for them and their family uh and amongst
them are not people that have an
nefarious intentions uh let let me ask
you this usually after four years the
president can ask a question are you
better off than you were four years ago
I don't think Joe Biden can run on that
as a matter of fact they have pretty
much telegraphed what they're going to
run on democracy in Peril Trump is evil
Trump is evil Trump is evil and
dangerous and you got to fear Him
January 6 January 6 and then the usual
Playbook Republicans are racist and
sexist and uh have every phobia known to
man whether it's real or not uh and they
want dirty air and water that's all
they've got I don't see any one issue
that Joe Biden can run on what will your
answer to their predictable attacks be
well that's all they have is right
because their economy has been terrible
the inflation is destroyed anybody that
made even a little more money even a lot
more money it more than got eaten alive
by inflation when you look at the price
increases of of energy of Housing and I
I mean rental housing I looked the other
day it's up almost
51% uh the cost of bacon quadrupled all
of these things I mean food costs
clothing costs it's so much that no
matter what you're making it doesn't
matter you know
inflation is known over the years over
hundreds of years it's known as a
country Buster it breaks countries it
broke Germany it broke a lot of
countries we've had the worst inflation
we've had I think in 78 years you know
they say 52 it's probably more than 78
it's been a disaster and all in the
wrong places I had no inflation and I
had the greatest economy ever we had
gasoline at a dollar 87 now it's four or
five dollar but by the way they're
working together with other countries
sadly because it's artificial because
they're going to give it up right after
the election you've seen that before but
they're working to get gasoline prices
down it's an artificial reduction but
the gasoline was up to six seven8 doll a
gallon and it still is very high it's
much too high but we had the greatest
economy in history and what else did we
have no inflation we had the safest
Border in the history of our country and
we it was like a beautiful a beautiful
thing was taking place we had a border
and I got Mexico to do a lot for us now
Mexico is saying we won $5 billion just
to talk Mexico wouldn't have talked to
me that way I have a great relationship
with the president but Mexico they had
to pay a lot you know they they gave us
28,000 soldiers free of charge to guard
our border and when they when I first
presented that to them they laughed they
thought I was kidding but through a
series of negotiations uh they gave us
everything we wanted stay in Mexico
remember remain in Mexico that was me
remain in Mexico nobody can come in the
remain you think Mexico was happy about
that they gave it to me uh catch and
release in Mexico I call it catch and
release in Mexico we had catch and
release in the United States and Mexico
did that they gave us things that nobody
can believe the state department
couldn't believe it the border patrol
people they couldn't believe it nobody
could believe it nobody could believe it
you know if you talk to Tom homman and
if you talk to anybody from border
patrol and they have great people they
have great people they'll tell you the
Great greatest president in history for
the border for immigration was Trump not
even a contest not even a contest let me
ask you about these states that are
trying to remove you from the ballot I
mean it's kind of ironic isn't it uh a
party that is making an argument that
democracy is in Peril uh couldn't be
more undemocratic as they try to remove
your name from even running and and even
having your name on the ticket now I
don't think this is going to hold I I
have to believe the Supreme Court will
intervene if there's real Justice it
should be a unanimous 90 opinion in my
view but what is your reaction because
you're the person they're trying to kick
off the ticket but they're the ones
claiming you're not Democratic pretty
ironic well we put on three great
justices and you have some other great
justices up there and they're not going
to take the vote away from the people I
mean I'm right now you saw in the
history of the Iowa primary I mean the
history of it it's a long goes back a
long time I won by the most nobody's
ever won as you know because you covered
it very well but everybody covered it
even the bad reporters covered it this
way there's nobody even close I doubled
up and more than doubled up the second
best now the second best it stood for a
long time as you know that record but uh
they want to make sure I'm sure the
Supreme Court is going to say we're not
going to take the vote away from the
people now by is a threat to democracy
he an absolute threat to democracy he's
very dangerous for a couple of reasons
number one he's grossly incompetent
which is the number one reason but he's
also actually in his own way it's not
him it's the people that surround him
you got some very bad people surrounding
him at that desk you have people running
the Department of Justice surrounding
him they're young and they're smart and
they're Communists and they're marxists
and they're fascists and they're running
this country they're running it right
into the ground but I don't think the
Supreme Court would do it because uh you
can't take the vote you know I'm leading
in every poll I'm leading Biden but I'm
leading the remaining Republicans there
two of them and they're barely hanging
on how can you possibly take the vote
away I mean just in the last two days
two credible polls suffk and St Anam
will right uh uh suffk nailed your
number in I think they were off by one
they had you at 52 not at 51 uh they
have you up I think by 16 now St Anam
has you up uh by 14
uh these are the most recent polls these
are post Iowa polls well that's Sean
that's in New Hampshire but if you if
you look at the national polls in the n
i mean in New Hampshire we're doing
great and take a look at the national
polls I'm up by 65 points I mean 65
points and I'm up by 11 12 13 points on
the
Democrats I know you have to run to uh
an event by the way our our our deepest
sympathy to uh the first lady on the
loss of her mom please please convey
that to to her for us well thank you she
was a great woman Sean what is your
closing message to the people of New
Hampshire it's very simple it's make
America great again but I think very
important before we do this because you
were talking about the Supreme Court
they have two votes that are very
important coming up one is as we discuss
we call it Colorado or whatever but you
know I I really believe they're going to
leave the people to vote again you're
the leading candidate in both parties
you're leading the Democrats by many
many points I mean it's hard to imagine
they would do and Most states have all
already approved it as you know very few
states have done that this is Colorado
and a couple of others at this moment
but they have another important and
that's immunity for the president the
president of the United States and I'm
not talking about myself I'm talking
about any president has to have immunity
because if you take immunity away from
the president so important you will have
you will have a president that's not
going to be able to do anything because
when he leaves office the opposing party
president if it's the opposing party
will indict the president for doing
something that should have been good
like Obama dropped missiles and they
ended up hitting a kindergarten or a
school or the apartment house a lot of
people were killed well if that's the
case he's going to end up being indicted
when he leaves office he meant well the
missile went in the wrong direction and
other things look at Biden what would
happen to Biden he's killed our country
with his policies the border is a
disaster everything he does is a
disaster what he did in Afghanistan is
the most embarrassing moment in the
history of our country giving them $85
billion worth of equipment killing our
soldiers wounding horribly our soldiers
and leaving people behind well when he
leaves office if he doesn't have
immunity now I think it's horrible what
he did but he probably I don't know it's
hard to believe but he probably meant
well it's hard to believe that he meant
well but the man is incompetent but you
have to leave you have to leave immunity
with a president if a president is
afraid to act because they're worried
about being indicted when they leave
office a president of the United States
has to have immunity and the Supreme
Court's going to be ruling on that if
they don't have immunity no president is
going to act you're going to have guys
that just sit in office and are afraid
to do anything by the way it is ironic
it took you a long time you were once
critical of me for pointing out Joe's
cognitive deficiencies uh I think it's
very transparent now for the world to
see I was more right than I thought I
was uh we're looking forward we'll see
in New Hampshire on Tuesday we really
appreciate your time uh thank you uh Mr
President for being with us we
appreciate it yeah Sean one thing I
wasn't critical of you I was critical of
you joking about it I wasn't critical of
you I I didn't you should be joking
about it I did and you know what you
were right at the time little that's
okay I actually I took it to heart I
mean that all right thank you Mr
President appreciate I know that thank
you very much thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else